Selamat datang kembali di quantum computing in practice. Episode ini bakal fokus pada langkah pertama dan seringkali paling
menantang dalam mendefinisikan program kuantum. Memetakan masalah umum ke sebuah circuit yang bisa dijalankan di komputer kuantum.
Langkah ini menjelaskan bagaimana pengguna yang mulai dari masalah komputasi tertentu
bisa menerjemahkannya agar komputer kuantum bisa memahaminya.
Di pelajaran sebelumnya dalam seri ini, pelajaran dua dan tiga, kita sudah bahas bahwa tahap pemetaan adalah langkah pertama dari
empat langkah dalam kerangka Qiskit patterns. Dari pelajaran-pelajaran itu, mungkin kamu ingat tujuan kita adalah menerjemahkan
atau menulis ulang masalah komputasi menjadi cost function atau nilai ekspektasi
yang bisa kita evaluasi menggunakan komputer kuantum.
Di pelajaran tiga, kita bahas satu contoh konkret dengan max cut, sebuah masalah
yang secara komputasi sulit dan umum dijumpai dalam optimasi kombinatorial.
Dalam contoh itu, kita melewati beberapa langkah untuk mengubah graf awal menjadi masalah yang native untuk kuantum. Kita
mengubah masalah menemukan jumlah maksimum potongan dalam graf menjadi cost function, lalu menulis ulang cost function itu
sebagai Hamiltonian dan menyiapkan trial quantum state yang ground state-nya
sesuai dengan max cut. Akhirnya, kita membangun quantum circuit yang merepresentasikan trial quantum state yang
kita minati lalu menambahkan gate-gate spesifik untuk memungkinkan state berkembang seiring waktu. Urutan langkah inilah yang kita
sebut pemetaan. Dan secara garis besar, prosedurnya berlaku umum untuk banyak aplikasi lain seperti kimia kuantum
dan simulasi kuantum. Sekarang, nggak bisa dipungkiri bahwa pemetaan itu bisa sulit. Nggak ada
strategi satu ukuran untuk semua masalah, jadi bisa bikin gentar. Hari ini, aku bakal menyoroti
beberapa contoh representatif dari berbagai masalah dan menjelaskan bagaimana masing-masing dipetakan. Aku bakal cepat
merangkum apa yang kita pelajari tentang masalah graf seperti yang digunakan dalam Max Cut dan menghabiskan sisa kuliah ini dengan fokus
pada cara memetakan masalah yang muncul di alam seperti masalah struktur molekul dalam biologi, masalah struktur
elektronik dalam kimia dan simulasi teori medan kuantum dalam fisika energi tinggi.
Tapi sebelum kita habiskan sebagian besar waktu di episode ini untuk melihat contoh masalah dari literatur, aku mau kasih kamu
gambaran umum tentang hal-hal utama yang ingin kita capai dan pertimbangkan saat memetakan masalah. Ada
beberapa hal yang perlu dipertimbangkan untuk jenis masalah komputasi apa pun yang perlu diterjemahkan ke dalam quantum circuit.
Pertama, mungkin kamu perlu menyederhanakan masalah agar bisa dilakukan. Ini adalah hal yang umum di sebagian besar disiplin ilmu
dan bukan hanya di quantum computing. Kalau kamu pernah dengar ungkapan asumsikan sapi
berbentuk bola, itu merujuk pada fakta bahwa seringkali sulit untuk mendeskripsikan sistem persis seperti apa adanya. Tapi
sebaliknya, kita bisa membuat penyederhanaan yang masuk akal yang tetap bisa menghasilkan solusi yang membantu.
Beberapa contoh cara kita bisa melakukan ini dalam quantum computing adalah membatasi ukuran atau kedalaman circuit dengan memilih
ansatz yang efisien untuk hardware atau memotong evolusi waktu yang kompleks atau mengabaikan
suku-suku Hamiltonian yang sedikit berkontribusi pada energi akhir quantum state.
Poin berikutnya yang ingin aku sampaikan adalah kamu harus memikirkan cara menulis masalah sehingga komputer kuantum bisa memahaminya.
Seringkali itu melibatkan tiga pertanyaan ini. Satu, apa yang akan direpresentasikan qubit-qubit kita
dalam model ini? Dua, apakah masalah kita kontinu? Karena komputer kuantum bersifat digital, kamu perlu
mencari cara untuk mendiskritisasi masalahnya. Dan ketiga, terakhir, apakah topologi masalah selaras dengan topologi
hardware-nya? Kalau iya, bagus sekali. Tapi kalau tidak, kita mungkin perlu menerapkan beberapa trik agar bisa berhasil. Jadi mari kita bahas
pertanyaan pertama ini. Apa yang aku pikir merupakan inti dari semua kesulitan dalam memahami pemetaan terutama sebagai
konsep baru. Apa yang bisa direpresentasikan oleh sebuah qubit?
qubit bisa digunakan untuk merepresentasikan banyak hal. Yang pertama dan paling sederhana menurut pendapatku adalah sebuah node pada graf. Graf
digunakan untuk menunjukkan konektivitas dan berbagai jenis masalah matematika. Dan node-node adalah elemen fundamental yang merepresentasikan sebuah titik
atau entitas dalam jaringan. Tergantung apa yang direpresentasikan keseluruhan jaringan itu, itu bisa berupa kota, orang, atau
ferromagnet dalam kisi. qubit juga bisa digunakan untuk merepresentasikan boson dan fermion. Meski aku akan memperingatkan di sini
bahwa satu qubit tidak sama persis dengan satu boson atau satu fermion. Ini sedikit
lebih rumit dari itu dan aku akan menjelaskannya sebentar lagi, tapi secara umum, rantai spin yang mengikuti statistik tertentu adalah
sesuatu yang bisa dengan mudah diterjemahkan ke arsitektur qubit.
Sekarang, kita masuk ke contoh-contoh yang sedikit lebih rumit. Untuk model-model ini, tidak lagi masuk akal untuk
bicara dalam hal satu qubit tunggal.
Sebaliknya, kita butuh kelompok-kelompok qubit untuk membentuk sesuatu yang fisik. Misalnya, sebuah
kelompok qubit yang direpresentasikan pada topologi heavy hexagonal bisa digunakan untuk merepresentasikan lokasi geometris asam amino
atau rantai polimer. Contoh lain adalah simulasi hamburan hadron
dalam model fisika energi tinggi yang bisa dilakukan dengan mensimulasikan evolusi waktu paket gelombang hadronik. Dalam kasus ini,
register qubit bisa digunakan untuk mengkodekan berbagai state dari medan kuantum. Vacuum state dari medan itu atau
paket gelombang yang merambat di atas vakum ini.
Sekarang aku juga ingin mencatat bahwa memetakan masalah ke komputer kuantum memiliki langkah-langkah yang berbeda yaitu satu memetakan
state ke qubit dan circuit dan dua memetakan cost function atau ekspektasi
dari observable dan operator kuantum. Kita akan lihat bagaimana ini ditangani dalam contoh-contoh spesifik. Tapi
pada titik ini kita sudah cukup bicara secara abstrak tentang tantangan yang ada di depan kita.
Mari kita lihat contoh-contoh ini sekarang secara detail.
Mari kita mulai dengan contoh pertama kita. Menurutku, salah satu masalah pemetaan yang paling mudah adalah yang sudah
kita bahas cukup mendalam, contoh max cut. Dalam masalah itu, pemetaannya cukup mudah bagi kita karena satu qubit
WEBVTT
sama dengan satu node di graf kita. Menggunakan node pada graf sangat intuitif dan itu
menguntungkan karena sesuai dengan banyak aplikasi. Banyak kali ketika kamu ingin memodelkan sesuatu yang sesuai dengan
serangkaian node yang terhubung bersama, jika pengelompokannya biner seperti nol atau satu atau termasuk dan tidak termasuk dalam
sebuah set, kamu bisa dengan sederhana dan natural memetakan node-node ini ke bit atau qubit.
Dalam contoh ini, bahkan dalam contoh yang kita skalakan hingga 100 qubit di episode 3, konektivitas graf
sudah cocok dengan topologi hardware superconducting kita. Jadi kita nggak perlu khawatir soal itu juga. Tapi itu nggak selalu kasusnya.
Dan kalau kamu punya graf yang lebih kompleks atau lebih terhubung dari contoh-contoh yang kita soroti sejauh ini, kamu akan
perlu menerapkan swap gate. Tapi ini sebenarnya ditangani di langkah kedua Qiskit patterns yang berkaitan
dengan transpilasi. Bagian lain dari masalah max cut yang membuatnya sangat berguna adalah bahwa kita
sudah tahu cara mengekspresikan cost function sebagai Hamiltonian menggunakan formulasi qubo.
Ingat bahwa dalam quantum computing dan algoritma kuantum variasional, cost function Hamiltonian adalah fungsi
yang mengkodekan solusi optimal dari masalah dalam ground state Hamiltonian.
Untuk membangun cost Hamiltonian, kita bisa menggunakan kelas sparse poly op dalam Qiskit untuk menentukan
konektivitas graf kita dan tahap pemetaan ke operator kuantum selesai. Dan quantum circuit-nya
tinggal ansatz QAOA. Nah, kalau ini nggak membuatmu ingat sesuatu, silakan kembali dan lihat episode 3 di mana kita
membahasnya jauh lebih detail. Sekarang, mari kita tingkatkan sedikit tingkat kesulitannya. Berikutnya, kita akan melihat
contoh yang dimodelkan dalam makalah berjudul resource efficient quantum algorithm for protein folding yang ditulis oleh
IBM bekerja sama dengan University of New South Wales. Sedikit latar belakang biokimia. Protein adalah
makromolekul yang terdiri dari rantai panjang asam amino. Rantai panjang ini melipat
dalam struktur kompleks yang menjalankan berbagai fungsi biologis.
Menentukan struktur protein dalam ruang tiga dimensi dan memahami hubungan antara
struktur dan fungsi termasuk dalam masalah paling menantang dalam biokimia saat ini.
Protein melipat menjadi struktur yang berguna karena interaksi antara asam amino itu sendiri.
Saat struktur memutar dan melipat, asam amino yang jauh satu sama lain di rantai bisa berakhir tepat di sebelah
satu sama lain dan mungkin berinteraksi dengan kuat. Kita perlu mendapatkan Hamiltonian yang mendeskripsikan semua interaksi antara asam
amino ini jika kita ingin memprediksi struktur akhir mana yang akan meminimalkan energi. Di sini kita akan fokus pada rantai asam amino dan
bagaimana rantai tersebut bisa dimodelkan pada komputer kuantum dan kemudian bagaimana kita bisa mendapatkan jarak antar asam amino untuk
perhitungan energi interaksi.
Dengan ini, kita sebenarnya sudah mengumpulkan semua kontribusi yang diperlukan untuk Hamiltonian agar bisa mensimulasikannya
di komputer kuantum. Pada protein nyata, asam amino bisa menempati kontinum lokasi yang mungkin.
Namun, kita akan menggunakan penyederhanaan di sini dan membatasi mereka ke model kisi di mana setiap asam amino
menempati sebuah titik pada grid. Di sini, para penulis menggunakan kisi tetrahedral.
Catatan singkat di sini, kita mengkodekan arah tepi dan bukan node itu sendiri seperti dalam masalah max cut.
Setiap qubit merepresentasikan kemungkinan jalur satu langkah di sepanjang grid tetrahedral. Perhatikan bahwa situs yang berdekatan telah
diberi label A atau B dalam diagram ini karena orientasinya yang berbeda dalam kisi.
Rantai protein direpresentasikan sebagai serangkaian belokan atau arah pada kisi
ini. Setiap belokan antara asam amino bisa berada dalam satu dari empat arah
yang sesuai dengan tepi tetrahedron.
Empat kemungkinan belokan ini dikodekan menggunakan empat qubit.
Ini terdengar agak rumit. Jadi mari kita lihat contoh ini sedikit lebih dalam.
Mari kita tempatkan rantai asam amino pertama kita di titik ini pada kisi tetrahedral. Arah ke
rantai asam amino pertama ke yang kedua bersifat sembarang karena sistem selalu bisa diputar untuk membuat tepi itu menunjuk
ke arah mana pun yang kita inginkan. Jadi mari kita tempatkan asam amino kedua kita di sini. Ini nggak
gampang dilihat, tapi jalur dari yang kedua ke yang ketiga sebenarnya juga bersifat sembarang. Ketiga pilihan itu akan
menghasilkan dua tepi dengan sudut sekitar 109,5°
di antara keduanya. Memilih tepi kedua ini hanya menentukan orientasi protein kita dalam ruang. Jadi tanpa kehilangan
generalitas sama sekali, kita bisa memilih belokan pertama menjadi 0 0 1 dan 0 0 1
0. Dengan penyederhanaan-penyederhanaan ini, konfigurasi rantai asam amino hanya dinyatakan dengan ekspresi ini.
Sejauh ini kita sudah memetakan tepi tetrahedron ke qubit dan quantum circuit kita akan menjadi sebuah ansatz. Sekarang kita perlu
mempertimbangkan cara mengkodekan energi masalah ke dalam Hamiltonian sehingga ground state-nya memberi kita pola
pelipatan yang optimal. Sekarang untuk konfigurasi apa pun akan ada energi yang terkait karena
interaksi antara asam amino itu sendiri. Interaksi ini paling kuat ketika dua asam amino
berdekatan satu sama lain. Jelas asam amino yang berdekatan dalam tulang punggung rantai akan selalu berinteraksi dengan
satu sama lain. Tapi karena protein bisa memutar dan melipat, pasangan asam amino lain
juga bisa berinteraksi. Asam amino 10 dan 20, misalnya, mungkin berakhir berada di
situs yang berdekatan setelah protein terlipat. Asam amino yang berakhir saling berdekatan memiliki interaksi yang lebih kuat
dan mendorong proses pelipatan, tetapi mereka tidak harus memiliki indeks yang dekat satu sama lain.
Jadi kita perlu rumus untuk mendeskripsikan jarak D antara asam amino I dan
J menggunakan informasi yang dikodekan pada qubit konfigurasi. Dengan begitu kita bisa
menggunakan jarak pemisahan mereka untuk menentukan seberapa kuat mereka berinteraksi. Ini sedikit rumit
tapi ikuti terus karena ini adalah trik yang bagus. Pertama, mari kita perkenalkan fungsi f sub a dari i yang menunjukkan apakah
WEBVTT
atau tidak tepi a digunakan untuk belokan di asam amino i. Di sini a bisa mengambil nilai dari
empat arah yang mungkin mengingat pengkodean konfigurasi di atas. Kita bisa menulis fungsi-fungsi ini dan kemudian kita
bisa mendefinisikan perbedaan jumlah belokan berlabel a pada kisi A dan B dari
indeks I ke indeks J sebagai delta N. Kenapa kita melakukan ini? Nah, ternyata
kisi tetrahedral memiliki properti yang sangat berguna. Mari kita fokus pada asam amino ini. Nggak masalah yang mana,
tapi mari kita sebut asam amino E. Kita ingin tahu seberapa jauh asam amino j. Dan yang kita punya hanya
tepi-tepi di mana tulang punggung melangkah. Mulai dari I perhatikan bahwa sebuah langkah
keluar dari pusat sepanjang tipe tepi tertentu sebutlah a dari situs kisi a ini
tepat berlawanan dan dibatalkan oleh langkah keluar sepanjang tepi a dari
situs b. Jadi banyak langkah sepanjang tepi A dari situs kisi A mana pun menggerakkan
tulang punggung menjauh dari asam amino E dan langkah-langkah sepanjang tipe tepi A dari situs B
membawa kamu kembali. Jadi jarak antara dua asam amino I dan J sepanjang tipe tepi
yang akan kita beri label A bergantung pada perbedaan antara langkah-langkah yang dilakukan sepanjang tepi A
dari situs A dan situs B. Karena A dan B secara bergantian bergantian dalam
tulang punggung protein, ini ditangkap oleh suku minus1 pangkat K. Dan argumen ini berlaku untuk tipe tepi lain juga.
Jadi jarak antara asam amino dalam langkah-langkah kisi tetrahedral bisa dihitung pada akhirnya dengan
ekspresi ini. Tapi bagaimana kita mendapatkan Hamiltonian dari persamaan panjang ini untuk total jarak antara asam amino? Ternyata
ada korespondensi satu-ke-satu antara jarak-jarak dalam langkah kisi tetrahedral dan jarak
Euklides. Dan kamu bisa lihat aku sudah menghitung beberapa ekspresinya untukmu.
Jarak-jarak ini bisa digunakan dalam menghitung energi konfigurasi kamu.
Tergantung tujuan kamu, kamu mungkin menetapkan jarak cutoff di mana kamu menganggap pasangan tersebut berinteraksi
atau kamu mungkin melakukan sesuatu yang lebih rumit. Mungkin nggak jelas, tapi kita sebenarnya sudah selesai dengan tahap pemetaan
dengan melakukan ini. State qubit menunjukkan belokan, dan kumpulan belokan menentukan
jarak antara setiap pasangan asam amino. Pasangan dari berbagai jenis asam amino
memiliki interaksi yang berbeda, sebagian atraktif, sebagian repulsif. Kalau kamu menggunakan konfigurasi dan jarak untuk
sekadar menentukan apakah interaksi asam amino yang diketahui aktif atau tidak, kekuatannya sudah
diketahui dengan baik. Bukan oleh aku, tapi kamu bisa mencarinya di tabel seperti ini. Jadi singkatnya, dalam
contoh ini, qubit digunakan untuk menandai lokasi-lokasi di kisi yang bersama-sama membentuk rantai asam amino.
Dan dengan mensimulasikan bagaimana mereka menekuk dan melipat, kita berharap bisa menemukan hasil yang lebih baik dalam penelitian medis. Sekarang, kita
melewati cara menghitung beberapa suku Hamiltonian karena sangat spesifik untuk masalah ini. Sementara mendefinisikan
arah pada kisi bisa diterapkan lebih umum.
Sekarang setelah kamu punya Hamiltonian umum, kamu selalu ingin menerjemahkannya menjadi operator Pauli yang
native untuk komputer kuantum. Itulah yang akan kita bahas berikutnya.
Ayo lanjut. Sekarang mari kita jelajahi cara menerjemahkan sistem partikel subatomik menjadi operator Pauli. Partikel subatomik
dibagi menjadi dua kategori. Boson dan fermion. Boson
seperti foton atau Higgs mematuhi seperangkat aturan statistik tertentu dan fermion seperti elektron atau neutrino mematuhi aturan lainnya.
Perbedaan utama antara keduanya adalah bahwa boson boleh menempati state yang sama. Nggak ada batasan berapa banyak
boson yang bisa berada di ground state atau state tereksitasi lainnya. Fermion di sisi lain bersifat egois. Mereka menuntut agar
setiap partikel memiliki quantum state-nya sendiri. Boson juga memiliki spin integer sementara fermion memiliki spin setengah integer
seperti elektron spin 1/2 atau partikel spin tiga setengah yang lebih eksotis. Untuk
mendeskripsikan sistem partikel, kita butuh deskripsi energinya. Mari fokus pada fermion. Kita bisa mulai dengan
Hamiltonian yang ditulis dalam bentuk apa yang kita sebut operator C. Ini pada dasarnya objek matematika yang
sesuai dengan menciptakan atau memusnahkan fermion dari sebuah state dalam sistem.
Ini sering ditulis sebagai fi dagger dan fi dalam notasi yang kita sebut kuantisasi
kedua. Sekarang fi dagger adalah operator yang menciptakan fermion dalam state i. Fi adalah
operator yang memusnahkan fermion dalam state i. Tapi ingat komputer kuantum biasanya beroperasi dalam
basis qubit dengan aturan spesifik untuk merepresentasikan sistem fermionik. Mereka tidak secara inheren bekerja dalam bahasa
operator fermionik. Untuk menjembatani kesenjangan ini, kita perlu memetakan notasi kuantisasi kedua menjadi operator Pauli yang
secara natural sesuai dengan quantum gate.
Ada beberapa transformasi seperti itu untuk fermion. Pilihan yang umum adalah transformasi Jordan Wigner.
Pemetaan Bravyi Kitaev dan paritas adalah yang lebih baru untuk pengkodean Majorana.
Operasi bosonik di sisi lain bisa ditransformasi menggunakan transformasi Holstein Primakoff atau dengan langsung
memetakan Fock state ke subbasis dari mode bosonik yang tersedia.
Dan ada pilihan lain untuk boson juga. Pengkodean lain juga sedang aktif diteliti. Tapi untuk sekarang, kita akan
fokus saja pada transformasi Jordan Wigner.
Jadi kenapa kita nggak langsung menetapkan satu qubit untuk merepresentasikan setiap elektron? Nah, kita nggak bisa.
qubit bisa dibedakan sementara elektron tidak. Misalnya, kita bisa dengan mudah memberi label dan mengidentifikasi qubit individual pada
perangkat mana pun, tapi ketidakdistinguisabilan elektron berarti kita sama sekali nggak bisa memberi label pada mereka. Kita sebenarnya perlu memberi label
pada operator berdasarkan orbital yang ditempati seperti 1s, 2s, dan 2p
bukannya elektron spesifik. Dengan demikian kita sebenarnya perlu memberi label pada operator berdasarkan orbital yang ditempati seperti 1s
2s dan 2p daripada memberi label pada elektron spesifik. Jadi setiap qubit berperan
WEBVTT
kira-kira sebagai orbital dalam molekul yang entah ditempati atau tidak ditempati.
Tapi bagaimana cara melakukannya sebenarnya sedikit lebih rumit. Jadi sekarang kita perkenalkan sesuatu yang disebut pemetaan Jordan Wigner untuk melacak
antisimetri dan memastikan bahwa statistik yang benar dari sistem fermionik keseluruhan sedang dipatuhi. Pemetaan Jordan
Wigner secara konseptual sederhana karena korelasi satu-ke-satu antara orbital dan qubit. Ada
pemetaan lain yang mencapai tujuan serupa termasuk pemetaan paritas.
Perhitungan paritas suatu state memerlukan pertimbangan beberapa qubit. Dalam pemetaan paritas dan beberapa lainnya, interpretasi
satu qubit yang sesuai dengan satu orbital tidak berlaku.
Sekarang mari kita telusuri contoh yang cukup sederhana bersama untuk memastikan kita memahami transformasi ini.
Misalkan kita ingin menghitung interaksi qubit tunggal f dagger f. Kita mulai dengan memasukkan definisi kita untuk
operator raising dan lowering. Kemudian kita bisa mengelompokkan suku-suku dengan memfaktorkan matriks identitas i dan 1/4.
Seperti yang kita lihat, kita tersisa dengan suku-suku yang akan terlihat familiar bagi mereka yang berhadapan dengan relasi komutasi. Suku ini
dalam tanda kurung tidak lain adalah i dikali komutator dari x tidak dan y. Dan jangan
lupa tentang identitas yang kita keluarkan.
Ingat ini hanyalah matriks Pauli. Jadi komutatornya sudah dikenal. Komutator dari x dan y dalam
urutan itu sederhana. Ini adalah 2 i z. Pastikan kamu tidak kehilangan tanda negatif dan kamu akan mendapatkan ini sebagai hasil
akhirmu. Pada akhirnya, kita berhasil menulis ulang ekspresi fermionik dalam
hal operator Pauli yang bisa dipahami oleh komputer kuantum kita.
Mari kita bahas secara cepat cara mengimplementasikan pemetaan Jordan Wigner dalam Qiskit karena meskipun aku pikir itu
penting untuk memahami bagaimana pemetaan dan transformasi serupa bekerja dan melihatnya dikerjakan setidaknya sekali, kamu
nggak mau harus melakukan semua pekerjaan ini secara manual setiap saat.
Terutama untuk sistem berukuran besar khususnya, kita bisa memanfaatkan fungsi sparse poly op dalam Qiskit untuk
dengan mudah membuat operasi Pauli yang terkait dari sebuah pemetaan. Implementasi yang tidak optimal
akan menggunakan nested loop dan membutuhkan sekitar 20 baris kode.
Aku akan cantumkan kodenya di sini untuk kamu eksplorasi. Tapi secara garis besar, langkah-langkahnya adalah sebagai berikut.
Satu, gunakan fungsi sparse poly ops from list untuk membuat operator identitas
yang sesuai dengan ukuran ruang parameter yang akan dipetakan. Dua, mengikuti definisi operator penciptaan
dan pemusnahan yang ditunjukkan sebelumnya, gunakan fungsi sparse polyops from list untuk mendefinisikan operasi Pauli x, y, dan z.
Ini akan memetakan operator penciptaan dan pemusnahan fermionik ke operator spin qubit yang mengkodekan bilangan okupasi fermionik
ke dalam basis komputasi qubit dan ketiga hasilkan Hamiltonian yang diinginkan
dalam basis Pauli dengan menerapkan operator di atas ke orbital yang diminati. Ini biasanya sesuai dengan
pembuatan matriks identitas yang merepresentasikan inti orbital non-interaksi dan kemudian menerapkan operator penciptaan
dan pemusnahan ke ruang aktif dengan bobot yang sesuai dengan spesifikasi masalah yang sedang dihadapi. Seperti
yang aku sebutkan, ini hanyalah ringkasan tingkat tinggi. Kodenya nggak terlalu rumit, dan sekarang kamu harusnya
merasa percaya diri dalam mengadaptasinya untuk masalah-masalah lain yang diminati.
Sekarang kita sudah sepenuhnya memahami skema pemetaan Jordan Wigner, mari kita lihat aksinya dalam pengaturan yang lebih rumit. Mungkin kamu
ingat makalah ini dari episode sebelumnya juga tentang dinamika hadron. Aku nggak akan meninjau makalah itu lagi secara mendalam, tapi silakan cek
episode sebelumnya kalau kamu melewatkannya dan penasaran. Dalam contoh ini, pemetaan Jordan Wigner digunakan untuk
mengekspresikan Hamiltonian situs kisi dengan L situs untuk model Schwinger tanpa adanya medan listrik. Di sini,
jauh lebih sulit untuk secara spesifik menentukan apa yang direpresentasikan satu qubit dalam model ini karena hanya
kumpulan qubit bersama yang membentuk sesuatu yang fisik. Dalam konteks ini, sebuah paket gelombang. Sebaliknya, kamu bisa secara kasar
berpikir tentang qubit sebagai potongan ruang yang didiskritisasi di mana di sini L adalah volume kisi di mana setiap elemen atau
sel satuan terdiri dari dua qubit. Operator fermionik yang kita lihat di slide sebelumnya mendeskripsikan amplitudo
fungsi gelombang di situs tertentu.
Jadi Hamiltonian kita mengandung operator raising dan lowering fermionik ini. Tapi untuk mengimplementasikan
Hamiltonian seperti itu pada komputer kuantum, kita perlu mengekspresikannya dalam hal operator spin, bukan operator fermionik.
Jadi kita gunakan transformasi Jordan Wigner. Setelah menerapkan transformasi Jordan Wigner, Hamiltonian baru kita
menjadi persamaan ini di bagian bawah slide di mana sigma plus adalah operator Pauli X + I Y dan sigma
minus adalah X - IY. Setelah kita punya Hamiltonian yang ditulis dalam format ini, bagian tersulit dari
tahap pemetaan sudah selesai dan sekarang bisa dengan mudah ditulis ke circuit dalam operator Pauli.
Sebagai ringkasan, kita sudah membahas empat contoh tentang bagaimana teknik pemetaan spesifik telah digunakan belakangan ini dalam
bidang quantum computing. Dimulai dari yang paling sederhana dan naik ke penerapan transformasi Jordan Wigner untuk
dinamika Hadron. Aku menyadari ini banyak sekali. Materi ini sangat teknis
dan kalau kamu belum pernah melihatnya sebelumnya, bisa sangat menakutkan. Kabar baiknya adalah aku janji itu akan semakin mudah dan
semakin familiar semakin banyak waktu yang kamu habiskan untuk berlatih. Dan itulah nama permainannya dan kenapa aku menamai seluruh
seri ini Quantum Computing in Practice.
Ini bukan sesuatu yang bisa langsung dipelajari siapa pun dari awal. Ini memerlukan beberapa pembelajaran, beberapa
waktu untuk berpikir keras, dan mungkin beberapa saat yang membuat frustrasi. Tapi aku mendorong kalian semua untuk duduk dengan ketidaknyamanan dan
benar-benar menjelajahi pertanyaan-pertanyaan yang muncul saat kamu terus belajar karena ini satu-satunya cara untuk benar-benar belajar. Terima kasih sudah
menonton. Ini adalah episode 5 dari quantum computing in practice. Lain kali kita akan menjelajahi cara mensimulasikan
Hamiltonian dari awal. Sampai jumpa.